[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello happy Monday we're backing smile
live of course I'm Eric that's Miguel
good morning good morning how are you
feeling today not bad a little bit this
this weekend four to seven because I am
the reviewer for GameSpot yeah you can
check out my review in progress which
went up last week plus a video component
which went up this weekend and you guys
are joining me as I continue to play
through the career which is proving to
be quite lengthy awesome so well bad
timing on my part but okay so there's
your car driving a BMW which one do you
got there I'm not I am m3 and 5-1 and I
think it's an m3 m3 but yeah these are
all the cars you have the cars with the
black backgrounds are the cars that I
have I even have a kind of like a limo
yeah because you would want to drive
I got a fastener Fury's car yes that's
part of the fast furious part of the
Ultimate Edition nice which that came
out I guess it allowed players if they
had the Ultimate Edition last Friday to
begin playing that's correct
whereas for everyone else they'd have to
wait till today
or twelve again what's interesting is
you could look at the left column they
take some inspiration on the surf Diablo
Disney's style of sorting sorting items
by rare Oh show me that hot Tier three
dodge demon fast and furious got a chip
Cana Oh is there a high OH legendary I'm
liking this guy's no I like this to loot
we are currently playing on a one just
an Xbox one we have a 1s in the office
but we're not playing on that right now
okay so you only got a couple as a
result of the of winning particular
races ok Porsche and also the Ultimate
Edition are you not using that Porsche
instead of your your I think at 96
it's just races a particular category oh
okay so it supports the game so there's
a lot of cards about that car porn right
yeah this this this rarity
classification a little bit arbitrary
because okay that's pretty much it
how are you using that one that is that
the one you're using them for might be
oh wait no you don't have enough credit
by it wait why is it why is the
background black
I don't know confused well here we go
also just so you guys know I will be
monitoring YouTube twitch chats game
plot as well if you guys have questions
that's Miguel can potentially answer I
will pass those along them as he had
mentioned he is the reviewer for the
game he has a review of progress
currently up but hopefully come what do
you think by tomorrow will have one yes
ok by tomorrow we'll have our full
review so stay tuned for that but until
now until then but we can check out
something yes so one of the things
that's in this game is a loot slash
crate component great yeah ok so ok so
as you say that is it something you earn
like pretty frequently or is this like
you can pay like is it more like a pay
to win kind of thing well you have to
use your credits ok you earned that your
erases but you can't use real money just
yet ok it looks like they'll turn 10
will add that component once the live
life it becomes a case of you gotta earn
money to me you have to spend money to
earn money because you have to spend the
same currency to buy these crates and
potentially you can get items that you
could sell for more credits some of them
some of the you install these mod cards
before races and if you fulfil the
requirements you could earn additional
credits so you lose that card once you
use it or that mod rather yes the dots
the dots that you see on the upper are
only get rated uses Wow okay and there's
a little bit of controversy right now
because initially the sell page of the
Ultimate Edition said that the VIP card
which gives you double credits was
unlimited use which was the case in
Forza Motorsport 6 ok but it looks like
this has 5.5 dots and after the backlash
on Friday
core fans the cell page on Microsoft's
website for Fort says 7 Ultimate Edition
they changed the language to clarify
that it is okay we go to a game oh did
you just burn that did you see snapping
all right I will burn you some comments
yeah you get a lot of comments if you
know anything about Luke Commons are
obviously comedy I was terrible I'm
sorry just see myself out so we do death
could one darn game not have stupid ass
crates in it I think this is a new thing
man I think that I don't think it comes
out of this crate that's fair I think
that if a game has like some type of
microtransaction it's usually a crate I
don't know what it is there must be some
there has to be market data out there
that says there's something about
opening a loot crate that people like
really enjoy and clearly is working so
like every game that has that is
generally gonna have that system some
maybe do it visually better than others
I guess but that doesn't really
necessarily excuse it I guess but it
just depends on if it's like a pay2win
situation versus like pay to look good
situation is how I like to put it like I
know path of Exile has a bunch of micro
transactions that you could purchase but
those are mainly primarily like pay to
look good you want to just look
different aesthetically whereas it's not
affecting the gameplay I don't like so I
asked you earlier do you feel like well
it doesn't have it yet right the micro
transaction the next stuff actually
isn't in the game yet well I mean I'm
finding that
a lot of cards and them I mean the mods
help sort of accelerate the your credit
earnings and considering this is a game
that you can get like I'm finding like
I'm getting an average of say like
20,000 credits per rapes per race that's
okay it's a lot but in the grand scheme
of things when there are over 700 cars
in the game yeah I don't really see this
so much as a as a pay to win type of
experience rather pay to get cars faster
okay that's good to know
right now we are playing on the Suzuka
track which has been in probably gosh I
remember this district going as far back
as poor position - oh nice I even even
checked the track in the track selection
screen full visit to this morning and
it's it's pretty much the same layout
but currently I am playing with my
favorite camera setting which is not you
know a simulation style yeah but I do
have my drive ATAR difficulty set to
what is considered above average okay
and there are I believe like five higher
difficulties including unbeatable these
okay I do want to have a fighting chance
and yeah I mean like obviously you're
gonna pick the
style that fits your playstyle best
right so it's good that there are
multiple angles maybe we can check some
of those out later okay or right now
Miguel is a confident man I always like
iron first
I don't want to jeopardize you losing
this race by you look at that hot rain
effects and they they must have a rain-x
because that that [ __ ] is just coming
off the windshield like no problem if
you've never heard of rain-x for your
car I would say it's worth it if you
definitely if you're in a like state or
country that it rains a lot in because
rain-x is like a godsend basically it
like hits your window and like pretty
much like falls off it doesn't like
stick to your glass essentially and it
makes it wiping in and whatnot a lot
easier to spot I just plug the rain-x I
guess no video games and car types of
accessories are what we do here as far
as I know Wayne X is not paying today to
say no I just think it's legit
as hell if you have ever driven and have
a lot of rain to deal with rain-x is
legit that's that's the last time I'll
sleep in it but I it looks great though
yeah I'm looking at this cockpit and
earlier this morning I texted my
neighbor who is a big Porsche nut nice I
was asking is there a name for the serve
like thug the mounds on the tenant to
position of the steering wheel for
better gripping because I mean I see
that in a lot of gaming steering wheels
he didn't actually he didn't have a name
for he just said grips but he actually
takes his Porsche out to Laguna Seca oh
wow and Sonoma Raceway which I believe
are the two closest tracks
[Music]
in the San Francisco Bay Area that are
in Fortson so I got a little bit of an
education about the nuances of both of
those tracks I shouldn't have been
surprised that there are names for every
straightaway and curve yeah these
world-renowned tracks that's awesome I
got a couple of supporters of rain-x in
huh that's which chat which is great
Gucci ride saying it's a legit also
renting the nacho man cabbage great name
also saying it's legit it's true so it's
like it's a like a wax for glass kind of
like I don't know how to exactly explain
it like I haven't used it in a while
but it like the amount that I put on
like lasted for a good amount of time so
I feel like even if you at least put it
on once it helps quite a bit but yeah
yes we are currently playing on an xbox
one just an Xbox one not an Xbox one X
you almost tricked me
it's like wait a second No ooh first
place look at that little slow-mo yeah
yeah Belmont you're got a Porsche and
you don't GG well played reviewer life
that's probably true man like Porsches
aren't cheap man I mean I'm trying to
track them to you I walked by his house
the garage door the open he's current
like modding his car but just like
moving stuff from the back he's got to
get lighter yeah right and like you know
half the stuff he tells me is it's kind
of Greek to me but I mean I just love
his enthusiasm and just like how
dedicated he is he talks about his group
of like a dozen friends who just like go
out to those courses like every other
weekend that's a lot I have a friend
that that tracks is like old m3 but he
goes like Craig once a quarter in the
year you know maybe twice it's not cheap
but he has fun doing it yeah he was very
excited to play the Porsche gt2 RS
in the demo okay which is not I believe
not they use the port that parts a car
to sell the demo and I remember they
revealed it as well at e3 but you will
not I did not get the chance to play
that in the full version I actually have
to buy it so let's say so credits are
being applied based on my mods yep so
quick question for you I guess are you I
mean obviously you're reviewing this
game for us come by tomorrow as the hope
are you gonna be doing anything again
once it comes out on the X or just kind
of checking it out to make sure
everything is all good I'll have to
check with Peter wearing that he wants
me to do anything
reevaluate it but I mean I'm gonna check
it out just out of personal curiosity
I mean if we're talking about you know a
high-end experience I mean I will say I
did spend some time on the PC version it
looks and performs great nothing that
was more any more visually impressive
than playing xbox one version but the
Xbox one version looks great as it is so
you can I'm guessing you can change your
outfit too yes that's one of the things
you can that's one of the things you can
get through the loot crate's okay
eyeballing it it felt like there were
like over a hundred different outfits
some of which were themed on other forts
of titles I beat you to the punch diva
Dixon VB he basically he or she
basically asked can you customize the
racers helmet tracksuit here we're gonna
check some of that out
I got quite a bit is there a tier system
for this - yes oh alright you know give
me a legendary look at that a little bit
of gold I'm into it I'm into it I'm
always about fashion in video games I'm
about that hot fashion now you can't be
using scrubbers man we Gary's but I like
that you're going through all of them
some of the UH some of the lower tier
sets still look nice I guess to be a
Nissan you know yeah I mean monster
branding shoutouts to monster yeah
that's like a very casual look and the
nice thing is you can preview some of
the stuff yeah that's a lot that's good
I like that
okay that one's crazy forts of logos
give me one of the legendary ones named
later when it's all decided to choose
it's it's all about personal taste I
mean I don't know I mean something retro
like this I would he told me it was
legendary I'd believe you
that was just rare wait what's super
rare that it's I think the one below
below legendary okay so they don't do
epic got it right I don't know it seems
unfair that all the legendaries are all
the branded ones Gucci ride asking a
Miguel did you use
steering wheel peripheral for the review
no ok gold here and I will admit when I
first saw these this kind of gear these
suits as one of the crate unlocks I
thought what was the big deal because
you're spending most of the time in a
cockpit anyway but you do see your
cameras and your VIP and you do see them
in when you're playing multiplayer and
I'm assuming you're gonna be also be
able to do that when you when leagues
open up but one thing I that also did
lend credence to like the value of these
students is also when you're driving
converting convertibles obviously you
will be able to hear
is our are those names other like
driving toms or they just AI just like
randomly name Dan well they're
technically drive Attar's
okay I mean all these folks are named
after actual players yeah but I am I
know for a fact that some of these
aren't are not people on my friend's
little Scotch my memory is hazy but I
mean I recall imports in for some
Motorsport 5 which I believe was the
first time bad drive Attar's everyone
was someone on your friends list whether
or not they had the game or not
we are currently 10 of 24 middle of the
pack you know which is fine
we just got a slowly creep our way up
there and again I am playing on about
what about or it's uh considers above
average and I'm trying to do my best to
try to be a polite honorable and
competitor here because that's how you
know that's what they do you know so
there's very little contact one of the
reasons why I'm anxious to actually
check out the other still lock
multiplayer modes is that currently the
only multiplayer you have is like
unorganized free-for-alls I see so
there's a lot of bumper cars there's a
lot of it's like unless your first play
I mean first on the track you it almost
seems like you have like no chance get
out of the way I'm not polite anymore
quite stunner Jaguars not I like how it
shows the detail of the damage that it
took and that it's you're the color of
the car are there repair costs when you
lose a race you know that's something I
need to I did not get that's your car
for you but one thing I've not really
investigate too much is the you can
actually take a pit stop that icon over
there on the right that's actually but I
can't imagine driving so roughly that
you would need to do that especially
when I mean davin the the career mode
has not subjected me to a LeMans like
24-hour raise so I've not had any reason
to use the pit stop
especially when the driver cars don't
use it all right so a couple of things
here so dick savvy be saying I assume
the outfits are also saved to drivers
are so your friends can see them through
the car when you show up in their game
or they just cosmetics just on yours
no you're fresh you will be able to
write yeah it's something to flaunt all
right so have you played a lot of GT
sport or like have you played GT sport a
bit a little bit a little bit um every
aspect of it has you know been that that
very intimidating level of Gran Turismo
sim style okay so I'm just gonna ask you
how those compared even though obviously
you know you play this more than you did
GT sport but just like maybe on a
surface level or you know I know
this is a word that we stray away from
another world I really do admire the
Polish of rennes trees moe okay there's
a certain there's certain like Forza
Motorsport installments I think like
five and six work this are like turn a
fetishize just you know Carl of yeah
they celebrate it with you know with
their top gear you know tie-ins with the
voiceover from the top gear hose you
know I sort of like I see it that's sort
of same level of like ceremony with
bread trees mode especially GT sport you
know just the amount of effort
the guys have polity digital like spend
on the menus and whatnot in the UI I am
looking forward to Gran Turismo sport
but I think I will be tweaking the
controls a bit because I'm not I'm
probably not gonna be fan of like
the turning on the controls like full
simulation that's right and it's always
been like a selling point of Forza that
these games this is sort of seen as a
much more accessible alternative get out
of your Mercedes
we know BMW superior good your AMG's no
good here yeah you let us buy that's
right you don't want to take more damage
whereas we don't care about damage we
care about winning all right you're on
lap 505 making progress you went from
tenth to fifth it's like cutting in half
we just got to get try to get a top
three finish here even if that means
taking some people out you go
that's just meaning talking a lot of
people are well they say a couple people
saying some of the previous courses are
better but you know that could just be
chat someone said horizon was better
someone said Forza 5 hits better than
this and I don't know that's true you
guys can keep to your opinions just find
a highlight yeah I mean one thing I am
disappointed in is that the server give
and take like turn 10 / Microsoft just
renewed the Porsche licensing agreement
so there's a whole there's at least two
dozen Porsches you get having this game
but this also I believe the first force
the game workers no production model
Toyota's really yeah which was very
disappointing to hear
just crossing my fingers okay I'm stolen
first
over all right over all yeah circle of
ice it's a it's a reference to a joke
from the British comedian Eddie Izzard
maybe someone in chat understands I'd be
very surprised if they did
hey technically akela Ezio they had
Dragon Ball at last e3 he basic this
switch comment they're saying Xbox has
only shooters and race games last year
was so funny from Microsoft board games
for everyone LMAO 40 games 38 shooters
to raise games no I don't there was a
couple I feel like there was some stuff
in there that you're not mentioning but
I cannot totally dispute it either I
just remember everyone got hype for
Dragon Ball so there's that I mean I
guess cuphead is a shooter yeah I wasn't
saying this cuphead fall on that I guess
it is it's like I like a platforming
shooter they call it a running gun style
so great game though I believe that was
reviewed last week by Peter Brown Joey
has put up a couple different features
if you want to unlock certain hidden
modes in that game you can as well
we got video up on that if you want to
find out how to do that but thank you
guys all for tuning in so far playing
some Forza Motorsport 7 we're going
through I believe he said story right
yeah the career yeah you're going
through a series of what feels like
maybe about five dozen seven dozen races
and going and it's basically just a way
for turn ten - just like packaged and
remix different car and track
combinations you know you could easily
set up these kinds of races and free
play
but you know this I've always been
grabbing it toward career because you
know it gives you gives you a lot of
goals lots of things to do and that
sense of achievement
you know beating the AI donjon f1 the
game releases tonight or tomorrow
morning depending on how you look at it
however if you had the Collector's it
was eliminate the ultimate ultimate
cheese I knew as a you were Ultimate
Edition you could have started playing
last Friday we are currently on the
Ultimate Edition Kurt also mentioning
from you teach at Toyota removed their
cars from all carvings so Dave I saw
some comments saying that like Toyota -
thought that having their cars and
racing games would discourage people
from bike kiotas like why you know what
you're gonna get if you're gonna buy
like a Camry and a Corolla - very solid
Toyota cars they last forever like but
you would never see in a racing game so
why does it matter so you've had those
cars take I have not but I just like my
friends I've had those cars and they
just literally last forever - had one
here he said he at his last Camry it was
like 300,000 miles or something which is
like pretty insane my very first car was
a Geo Prizm which was essentially a
Corolla nice how long did that last
I think it probably racked up maybe a
hundred twenty thousand miles across six
years so 2000 you just lost your
sideview he didn't need it anyways we're
getting the car lighter
Phil Elliott asking does any of the
weather effects affect weather effects
affect the frame rate on consult it
didn't seem like it did no so I think
you should be good on that front I mean
granted we've only seen the rain on time
this is apparently a very hard track Wow
you can do it sounds kind of weird on
you that looked like a bird that like
flew into the ground what I think is
this apart that phased out of it
[Music]
I don't know if they retro actively
removed cars Dave
the raid could just be for like
so one thing I'm really curious about is
I activated this mod for to give me X
own experience that credit or good
drafting uh-oh and I stood I was driving
behind that guy for good what felt like
five seconds and I didn't get any credit
for drafting maybe he didn't draft him
proper I don't know I mean I've been
playing I've been playing this game for
a good ten hours and I have not once
gotten credit for any kind of good
drastic but at the way I always I do get
recognized frequently for good passing
great passing and great cornering I have
to I have to say I appreciate the damage
that's being racked up on this car it
seems pretty spot on your taillights out
you just rubbed all of your car onto
that guy's car like I thought you're
being a nice guy trying to happen it's
okay it's because I put it in your head
that winning was everything no I want to
win because I want to get to the next
Cup Oh gotcha okay moon shield 84 if
there are no Toyotas just probably no
Lexuses cuz they are the same thing it's
like you guys know the beer Stella
Artois I think I'm saying that right so
you know that they're owned by they're
either owned by like Bud Light or our
sorry Budweiser or like Coors so like
Estela is like their their premium brand
kind of how like toyota used to have
Toyota Scion which was like their lower
tier brand which they've now killed off
and then they had Toyota normal and then
they had Lexus so many interesting
thorough Lexus Bruno Miguel asking
Miguel can you customize the cars as in
like the engine etc like in Gran Turismo
there is a lot of tuning but I don't
know if I haven't sure I need to check
where that you can do like whole like
whole swaps yeah okay
fair enough but the tuning is pretty
deep that's good that was good yeah ooh
spotless that time I liked it
referring to some of those comments
reference saying forts are horizon
I will admit I actually do as someone
who prefers our Kade racers over sims I
do get more excited for forts in horizon
than I do motors yeah someone else had
mentioned that earlier
oh so Curt giving me clarification here
oh yeah that Toyota will have race cars
in the game though yeah so it's just a
yeah they I've already checked it they
do have like professional racing cars in
this game gotcha
it looked like I eyeballed it maybe like
five or six okay but yeah you can't get
production office
I believe this is the last race in this
particular tournament
I think Justin blue he's saying Lexus
was invented because someone didn't
think of Americans or didn't believe
Americans would buy a sixty thousand
Toyota $60,000 Toyota I could see that
yes well this brings it's all about
branding right it's supposed to give you
this next tear-filled not like you're
just buying Camry but hey good enough
what do I think about bananas asked
midnight costs I think they're good I
guess they're they hope you not cramp we
got we got a whole bunch of bananas in
our break room today oh yeah sorry we
have like free fruit on Monday and
Wednesday not to promote healthy eating
dan look at that guy he's got like a
little night he's got a nice sweater
that's he looks like he's ready to it
like he could take off his racing hat I
guess cuz it's old school and his
goggles and he could go into a business
meeting like it was no problem
alright so you want that one pretty good
man you're using your legendary with no
no fear huh all right well I respect the
man well this this one this one there's
no risk I should probably just save this
for the longer races because it just
essentially doubles your yeah but once
you use them all it's gone right so
there's a risk you'll be holding the
ports of drivers Cup the first you have
to win the Masters championship
you gotta win the Masters champion you
got two more hurdles
yeah plantains are pretty good I'm not a
huge plantains man do you know what we
call enjoying um deep fried do you find
the handling hard with a controller and
that was Steve cab 46 wait that was we
do these Nissan cars are actually
supposed to have different colored hoods
I always thought that was usually at the
wall I haven't played the game but
usually add a carbon-fiber hood to
lighten the car right so I just thought
people who drove those cars just never
took care of their hoods Wow no yeah
it's usually there's a reason nice the
Soviet ookay championship to sharpen
what you've learned so far
Phil ill I said maybe it was just a
stream that's a bit choppy that it's
possible I mean it's always hard to
translate the look and feel of a game be
a stream like the exact look and feel
because obviously it's being like I'm
encoded and compressed a little bit so
and then it also depends on like your
internet back at home like what quality
you're able to watch but it was totally
fine on our end all right so we got to
do the Masters now right right does that
mean you won all of those that's the
thing right all these check marks
represent races that I want and also you
only want like in the case of yeah in
the case of the game's accessibility yes
you could actually complete campaign
without partaking in all the races okay
yeah it's just ya know its various story
right yeah I mean I don't know I mean
story I could see them forcing you to
complete all the races but I think it
allows you to just stay within your
comfort zone if you're that type of
player because I gravitate toward
European and Japanese sports cars so
theoretically I could probably continue
to do that yeah I will in this game I'm
not a fan of like you know muscle cars
and fishtailing but I mean I've had to
dabble in icky cheeks for the purposes
of this review I was like thinking maybe
we could just take
either actually looking so alright
election let's take a look take a second
how you played that much multiplayer and
the sheet Belmonts asking how it is it's
not bad I am looking I am looking
forward to league's unlocking because
more organized races you're on the same
page with everyone else meaning you will
actually respect each other and try to
play fairly
because right now playing multiplayer
it's just a lot of just people not being
polite and hitting each other so that's
not fun that's D lamb had as he we as we
had just talked about in regards to
carbon-fiber hood is it's lighter so
it's a weight modification which we've
talked about ro Johnny W is it hard
overall nice Jersey or an FRS I always
confuse the two
so it it's this that's the Subaru one
right so it's a what it's because they
like had that stupid collaboration and
they look like so damn similar and then
now Saiyans don't even what was that car
I won that one the spec our Silvia yeah
nice hmm all about that car porn
it's what Ford says though I learned a
lot today
he's carve out about me loot and car
porn these yo these codes oh the hoods
looks nice I'm not a fan of like the
gold but that's just my personal take on
that I didn't I try to get to all the
questions guys if I missed it too you
can always ask maybe a second time so
kill screen says let's see some Formula
One I don't know if you guys know X
Games water Daniel Dwyer and X giant
bomber do Scantlin but they love the f1
it'd be interesting another distinction
between formula 1 and formula e I mean
look what formula is manufacturer
I got another request PBT donat DJ 88 do
a race that walking's glen you know what
we can do that okay and then here's cut
here comes a question from Bruno Miguel
compared to Gran Turismo are there more
modes in four to seven than in Turismo
like more things to do and he thinks it
seems so but also asking you know I
think there might be more modes in Ford
sub but don't quote me on there
gotcha fair enough
Oh GM aids currently if you didn't buy
Ultimate Edition for Forza 7 you
wouldn't be able to play it until
tonight so that is currently the only
way you'd be able to play it ahead of
time
alright so alright I like it you switch
cars know what's your color of choice I
like the white that you had on the last
the previous car your m4 or import or
maybe a silver but that's fine that's
alright
I think I still VI must be that specific
color and that's what it is hey guys
thanks for the clarification on formula
eat ozium ate can't even buy it through
the though because there's no purchase
money I'm not sure that's kind of weird
Formula one cars are hybrid wouldn't I
mean I assume that was a recent
development huh yeah I don't know too
too much about that front I know my
friend just invested into a Tesla
because he wants to go full electric so
that's a thing and also because I think
it has like some bit of like auto
driving I guess but I don't know too
much about that end of it I'm gonna
pollute the earth
what am I supposed to do
Josh it's either Josh Lim lamer or Josh
Lamar man sorry if I butchered your last
name they're basically asking more broad
general question not so much about
portside but how do you like your
overall Xbox experience I'm thinking on
switching from Playstation
for me personally I haven't had enough
games on xbox to warrant me flying an
Xbox the funny thing is there was one
game that almost came out that was
supposed to come out this year that was
going to potentially get me to buy an
xbox but then they canned it and that
game was scaled down for me and so then
now I just don't necessarily have a
reason to switch from PlayStation 2 Xbox
I guess but that's just me personally
like I I've never been huge on Halo
never been that big on Gears of War so a
lot of their exclusives just don't
necessarily resonate for me but I think
that's different for everyone I think it
also depends like if you have a group of
gamers friends that plan a specific
console you know if there's more of your
friends playing on xbox that might sway
you to you know move move consoles but
what about you Miguel
I mean having exclusives help I mean I
mean if you're a really big driving fan
I think you might I suspect you might
have a better multiplayer experience
playing forts in Gran Turismo that's
sort of like my gut feeling yeah
but I mean it speaks to just the library
of games on the PlayStation 4 but you
know some of my favorite games this year
have been Mir and neo wait yeah neo is
on PC you know yeah there was the
announcement today of neo and PC which
you know I don't blame a lot of Xbox
fans for assuming that that might come
to Xbox but there's no official word on
that mm-hmm
I hope it plays great on PC [ __ ] I think
our our one of our tech editors is
actually finishing up a feature on worst
pc ports but overall I've been more of a
PlayStation person than Xbox is
generation it does know I will add
though ports Motorsports seven was
pretty much the first time I really got
a chance to really try out the play
anywhere feature because as someone
who's been reviewing this game both at
work and at home yeah just jumping from
my home xbox to the Xbox here plus the
gaming PC that are built for me it's
been transitioning from say from from
platform to platform has been very has
been seamless
oh and there's one thing the other thing
I want to add is I love that the play
and wear feature actually recognizes
that hey we know you're starting on this
platform we notice you have save files
on these to other platforms which one
would you like to use okay it's a nice
feature yeah I think also the other
thing I'm under playing or I haven't
mentioned is that backers kapow be Lisa
seems pretty good too we were playing
Halo 3 last week when it because it
turned 10 years old me and John Luke and
that seems to be great functionality so
there's also other benefits but it's
it's about the games right ultimately
and
the games just aren't as impactful for
me personally I have some fun facts
coming through the chat just in terms of
like car knowledge and stuff like that
so really appreciate you guys chiming in
giving us the lowdown kill screen saying
Tesla's are fast AF you know what that
means but they lack the soul of an
engine yeah surprisingly Tesla
apparently like the acceleration of a
Tesla it's like we're really fast like
faster than like more cars than you
would think and then D Lam for prez kurz
K capital K ers is the kinetic energy
regurge wondering if he spelled that
wrong that that part of the thing wrong
but it's a system that turns a thermal
energy that is produced under braking
and utilizes it to power other wheels
and systems on the f1 vehicles that's
how the hybrid system works in f1 sorry
I that one word I cannot say properly I
want I want to say like regurgitate was
obviously nice reach it's almost like
regenerative but it's not so sorry you
guys can read that chat if you've missed
it all right porta 7 should be out
tonight's 9:00 p.m. I would assume which
is 12:00 a.m. that's 4x plane 94 xx
if you want to save the earth get a BMW
I I can't afford that car so much so I
was amused at this far camera angle sort
of gives up a vignette like look on the
corners oh yeah which is something that
I've learned a lot about in our YouTube
thumbnails see neo on the PC oh man my
campbell of waiting paid off good job
the Mad Hatter or 86 the man had her Pro
sent the review should hopefully be up
at 9 p.m. like around the embargo if not
by tomorrow definitely Kurt saying I had
to turn off the camera shake it gave me
a headache after a while have you had
any of that I've noticed it it has not
given me a headache okay so it was
regenerative so there you go yeah that
was the word I was missing
but there's also another person saying
kinetic energy recovery system its
recovery
okay thanks to Chris a and Paolo
DeFreitas for that I should also add
that I started my playthrough when Xbox
when I got the new UI update for my xbox
and I will say it is uh it is actually a
noticeable improvement ok the last
couple you eye updates to my xbox one
have been a real headache mostly because
of just I still hate the UI though yeah
just from like unresponsiveness yeah I
guess what did they sunset the like this
that snap feature where you could like
have multiple apps running while you're
playing but I've not seen that in recent
updates
Joshua if you were looking forward to
the backwards compatibility and wanting
to play for Zaheer's award I would say
that you know obviously go get a Xbox
especially if you can afford it then the
question for you will be do you hold off
and buy the One X or you just buy a
normal Xbox one I guess that depends
like if you have a 4k TV etc but you
know do that if you want to kill screen
asking a fun question what do you guys
drive in real life he drives a 98 Ford
Expedition what do you drive
Miguel I don't share car that's right I
Drive a 2010 a Ford Escape okay my I
occasionally steal my wife's Mini Cooper
nice okay I Drive a 2006 BMW 330
basically a 90 wasn't my first choice of
car but my stepdad sold it to me at a
very good deal of which I could pay like
in installments
basically monthly so nice first place
great job you guys should make the
driver tours harder it is indeed
recovery says Chris hey thanks I didn't
know it so either way it's fine thank
you
God Philly's driving in 1994 m3 awesome
g jg g-man g-man I do have a 2017 Subaru
BRZ thanks
o San there the the Subaru people coming
out at sandy Spiker Oh three Impreza WRX
always wanted a WRX I always thought
that the pride wall is impressive but
like always thought WRX price was pretty
fair it's like in that mid-20s could get
a little higher depending on the the
add-ons that you get but and you get
four wheel drive and it sounds nice my
friend in college always had one or had
one and I always thought that's pretty
good car I could maybe get I could see
myself I'd be afraid of driving them
present because I think I would just
like fun that's the problem I will
probably get too much fun out of it
nice it is that it's bad enough that I'm
driving around San Francisco with my
Ford Escape and the Mini Cooper like
their sports cars yeah
did and that answer is six SVD dicks of
Edie's question do you actually drive in
San Francisco though I Drive a little
bit
because it makes more sense for me now
to carpool to work instead of taking
bark because like ultimately it saves
some time and it's about comparable in
price but if I was by myself I probably
would be just driving to the BART which
is basically not using my car
the way it should be which is like on a
freeway you know the Autobahn
essentially I finally got my name at it
who are in building parking wait oh you
were well waiting out dude yours that
doesn't mean name yeah I know Thai route
they gave me but what number was
whatever okay no you tell me what number
you are actually fine I'll tell you what
number tie was and then it'll make you
prime or said Thai was number seven on
the list and over two years I believe it
was two years Thai route former gamespot
he I think a year and a half to two
years he never moved or if he did he
only moved like one spot and it's got to
be worse now because we have Apple in
the building now too so I don't know how
many spots there allotted anyways I am
number 24 really yes
okay yeah you're not got more cars
coming through not sure if some are real
or not but you got a oh seven Shelby GT
and sixteen GMC Sierra that's Rama Luton
that's awesome
Colton Vic says he drives a he or she
drives a 2017 320 i M Sport nice 2016
Ram 2500 Cummins diesel says Zimmer 21
2001 honda accord represent the Honda's
baby my first Honda was a civic 89
hatchback that had no power steering and
only four years that was a that was a
fun car but also had no power
I just last night I was reading the I
was getting clarification on the
distinction between Shelby's and
Mustangs so that was interesting to
learn Nicolas Oh Shh sorry if I put your
life in 2011 Civic Si nice
did you play project cards - a little
bit there you go they're asking for a
comparison between the German project
cars doing this if you weren't a fan
that obviously kind of answers that
question Johnny Blaze 20 2016 Lexus
rc350 F Sport Dixon TV want to feel bad
Jeff Gerstmann ESEA Giant Bomb
essentially had his own parking space
when he was sacked when he came back
with Giant Bomb
they gave him his space back jeonhwa or
GameSpot people even lose out on the
waiting list of people who were fired
hey there's no there's a strong legacy
there and he was a founder I think
that's I think it's totally fair bear
claw 34 2010 a Subaru Forester keepo
common guys de lamb for pres 2012 be 63
wagon I might have missed that earlier
sorry
rambro 189 oh three Civic type-r wow
there's a lot of cars coming through
this awesome
bogs oh seven cobol's SS four four five
WH whoa are you all like the same car
right now there's repping Mercedes hit
up my boy and while we're on the topic
of air ones cars I will add that I
recently sent some interview questions
to the founder of positional huh who
does Jeep and he is going to reply back
with a list of all the cars that's
awesome that's awesome
Phillip Stephens 2014 Mercedes e350
diesel wagon
Joshua crow Wells getting back to me
about the price of a BMW i8 turns out as
153,000 no problem that's just like six
or seven cars you know like like your
father-in-law's asking for a full price
uh well no no no he's telling me to get
the ia which is like I think the and
your electric car for BMW which is not
cheap obviously cable dog 85 a 2015
Subaru WRX as I said solid car oh it's
nasty 2016 TC RS 10 just in blue po6
Mustang GT
that was another car that I like that
there went through this period of time
for me where I just saw a lot of Mustang
GTS
but I think it's because it's like in
that good affordable range where it's
still like a nice fun car to have
alright we in the the cockpit view the
one the one little touch I do appreciate
this game is the reflection of the earth
of the dashboard in your hands oh the
little reflection yeah just see that
touch and there's a there those little
touches that probably existed in other
forts of games but some for some reason
I only noticed it
it really feels very prominent
Twitter is not a fan of this speedometer
thinks it's the worst
Forte's has ever had you know I I get it
I mean you know everyone has a different
taste on aesthetics and you I I don't
get why certain outfits are legendary
aside from the fact that they're Monster
branded hey it's all about swag nasheed
Belmont drives a Celica 2015 series they
still have sell offence feel like I
don't know if you're serious on that one
I just I'm not that big of a car head
though so toxic 21:44 97 grand Jeep
probably Jeep Grand Cherokee classic
Zimmer wife drives a 16 and Cherokee
trailhawk what's up Bob Jones how are
you doing welcome to check Phil Elliott
says I live in Paris sold my car as it
was pointless to own one with all the
Parisian traffic that makes sense also
like I think you want to have smaller
cars right in Europe that's why I like
you know like a Fiat or like a Mini
Coopers probably Creole II good so you
know I remember my family driving us on
a summer vacation
in like the mid-80s fun time we're a
family of six G's gonna 5c during
meiosis oh we don't condone that here at
GameSpot okay no sitting in the trunk em
ones creation I have four to six it came
with my xbox one this force does seven
have more customization than six you
know that's a that's something I need to
spend some time on today because well I
did find the tuning to be as deep if not
deeper than other reports of games yeah
I really should do a compare and
contrast thanks okay
hello current Tom welcome to the chat
thanks for stopping by
let me see if I'm up to date
these messages up all right I'm caught
up
whoo
as mentioned earlier we're just naming
some of the cars that we actually drive
ourselves there's been a a nice mix I
feel like of different various styles of
cars
this car this odometer is in limited
edition there's one they only meet what
only 25 of these cars okay that's hey
now you're driving one
[Music]
pretty well though you can see by the
red dots on the lower left that they're
about that far behind
Steve cat 46 he's currently playing on
above-average or what the game deems is
above average which he feels is a good
fit for him so we're gonna stay on that
note I will admit I'm staying here
because I'm on deadline that's correct
you also have that review that you need
to finish tonight today
yeah there's a whole bunch of sort of
well known for its features that have
not been I guess been available yet
which I assume some will be available
when the game officially launches
tonight a couple of those includes forts
Athan which was I believe introduced two
forts through Forza horizon three timed
events and especially leagues believe is
sort of the big one in a way it's it's
almost like it reminds me of clans and
also just yeah a way for as I mentioned
before people multiplayer to sort of
group up and actually play organized
races without having to worry about
someone being very playing unfairly and
just like bumping and everyone today I
to get first something that simulates
more of like so basically should we
should I say that we should be more
likely to expect your review tomorrow
because some of these features okay
sorry
so I kind of lied to something here cuz
Ruby will be up tomorrow so that he can
test some of these modes that will come
out on like actual copper rings again I
didn't mention that if you had ultimate
edition of 4 to 7 here obviously playing
or have played that's how we're playing
we're playing on a xbox one this Xbox
one
yeah who's Miguel the reviewer currently
playing someone we said we're still
doing story right mm-hmm so it's cool
that they they pitch you into some other
types of like races yes kind of cars so
it's not always your and like other
forts of motorsports there are a couple
novelty modes where we take the car
bowling you race you do one-on-one races
you do there's one competition right
there like past 36 cars so this is forza
motorsport 7 is not short on variety
justin bloopy yes correct GameSpot
assigns reviews based on the fact that
the the reviewer has you know in this
case where there's like seven of these
games has played some of them before and
also enjoys them as the God mentioned I
believe you did our reports a six review
right yes yes
so plus Forks of horizon three three
and I did a Barnes guide for what so
right - yeah what sunrise at you
yeah their review of eat tomorrow I
loved Ford sell Rison - I think it's
probably my favorite towards because it
was an open-world racer with a coastal
setting as someone who who lives in
California you know it reminded me a lot
about driving along the Pacific Coast
Highway I would absolutely love an
open-world racer that is set in the
Pacific Coast Highway
Kurt we probably won't be doing too much
testing with a wheel for four to seven
so that's just that Chris a asking a
question to me but I'm gonna direct it
to Miguel because I don't play that many
racing games I haven't played a racing
game since like like like properly
played a racing game since like Ridge
Racer on ps2 basically not including
graphical elements what features would
you choose to include in four to seven
to make a more of a game suitable for
racing communities and clans don't know
if you have an answer for that but
that's just I hope those kinds of
features will be will be featured and
leads this turn is than getting it yes I
like because right now currently
multiplayer has not been a lot of fun
because of this the way people are
racing right because you're saying that
people are running into you they're not
really thinking about trying to avoid
yeah fair play so have you've done some
multiplayer then correct correct what's
the maximum or what's the total amount
of cars racing online at one time I
suppose main use like 24 okay so what it
is right now
[Music]
Dick's IVD asking if you crash and ruin
the front does the hood ornament of
magically stay
I don't know if he's damaged the front
of his car so bad that that would happen
we could turn it over into a wall across
the oh okay wait
oh the game was like wait a second no
you're not to each their own nasheed
Belmont he's like he says he likes need
for she's more than for it's over
project cars but that's because it's
more of an arcade eraser than like a sim
right oh absolutely love Need for Speed
I mean I'm excited enough for Need for
Speed that I just I played I played the
new one as much as I could
even if I will not be around to
especially because I won't be around to
play the final version for chat Josh a
lamer asking what's the big differences
between horizon 3 and was a mortar
sports 7 oh I would consider horizon to
be the more arcadey game okay it's open
world it's not more goal oriented
I think horizon does a better job than
motorsport in acknowledging like moment
to moments skill the fact that you can
get all these credits and points for
doing everything from drafting to near
misses to really close passes that stuff
I find it's great and motorsport
I'm still the you know the jury is still
out on like how how the sort of the
moment-to-moment
like performance crediting is a
motorsport again I've been acknowledged
for good passing and making good
cornering but despite the fact there's a
mod card specifically to drafting I've
not been credited with any kind of
drafting no matter how long I stay
behind someone oh yeah in completing
this mercedes-benz
see the one the interesting thing is I'm
my collection score is going up it to
the point that's an actually its
categories of six seven and eight I
don't know those numbers are arbitrary
at this point because there apparently
aren't any card rare days beyond five
stivic seventy-eight you can turn up the
AI if you want to um all the way up to
like what was the last unbeatable
unbeatable I almost said unwinnable like
a same thing unbeatable if you want to
Joshua Cromwell says there Crowell
sardis GT sport gives you penalties for
running into people even if it was an
accident
what's GameSpot are you body no we I
think if there are more viewers than
normal it's just because we had twitch
home page promo GameSpot is a news and
reviews website we do not sell games
like Game Stop nor do we buy or trade
oh yeah wait what are we doing here
we're doing bowling oh we're doing
bowling do this this has to be the car
for that oh no strike still no strike
you know that's one thing I will say is
like about this game being a little too
easy and accessible and forgiving I mean
I think you're supposed to be I think
the game is supposed to like encourage
like drifting yeah
but the goal target is super easy to
achieve
he was like Drive there goes amazed and
still get you should be aiming for
strikes
ah missed by one I don't think this game
rule I mean like rewards that's the
difference between the orange or brown
and orange pins give you a little bit
not doing that great with this limo
right now but I wouldn't expect you to I
guess and another thing you also get
unlimited rewinds in this game do-overs
Oh kill screen I believe you also get
nice cars just from loot crate's which
you can buy with credits right right and
you also get discounts nice discounts
I'm all about discount light is that a
limo yes it is
what's up Laurens bowls say I already
reached a goal target I'm nowhere near
to finish
all this
CJ def puso are the Poussin would you
say that horizon is a game with arcade
elements in a sim racer as sim racers
always show cars racing in stadiums and
so forth and defer that to you I mean
horizon is an open-world game the last
the last one was based in Australia or
you can go from like an urban setting
that is reminiscent of like the big
cities in Australia to a jungle in like
less than five minutes yeah it's very
arcade
what's up it's creeps welcome to chat
are you doing Phillip season Stephens
says don't forget about ports or rewards
every Friday bonus credits yes and you
do get daily rewards for how well your
driver driver to our competes in other
people's games
well technically killscreen they're said
in chat that I like that game saw it
stays mostly focused on games I didn't
turn into a catch-all for Hollywood news
comments in TV technically we do have
our sister site GameSpot universe they
cover the entertainment the comics TV
Rick and Morty breakdowns and things
like that but games Bob you know proper
we here are playing the games so if you
are interested in that type of content
or those types of videos or breakdowns
of shows the case lot universe is where
to go you have to win buddy and that
crew are doing a hell of a job all right
I say we do like one more you guys maybe
go do some menus probably called a
wonderful day a wonderful Monday playing
Forza Motorsport 7 here with Miguel who
is the reviewer of the game his review
in progress is currently up if you're
curious about his early thoughts of the
game but his final thoughts and review
should be out tomorrow sometime he's got
to do some more testing tonight when the
game comes out proper when there's some
modes and things that unlock right
that's I've heard box I heard about this
broken record me my Porsche fanatic
neighbor we're talking about it but that
would be that'd be a good youtube video
to this happen so just to give context
beam box and YouTube chat saying I know
you're doing career mode but you could
you try to beat the six minute 47 second
lap time record on nerve ring nerve
Nurburgring can't say that track
properly sorry if I'm butchering back
with the 2018 Porsche gt2 RS
it's the fastest road car beating the
nine one eight by 10 seconds that would
be a good video if we could pull it off
I definitely don't have the racing
skills to try to pull that off so you
know so there's a passing challenge I
believe oh oh this type of race where
everyone gets to go yeah yeah oh that's
a GTR isn't it that the lights made
well it's manual so yeah Nurburgring
thank you
that romanization of it helps read it
wow that Copic looked insane that was
from Philip in YouTube chat okay oh man
ah this is real it's real weird look at
where you're like sideview mirrors are
too this is crazy I'm not even going to
try to say that word - Chris eh that
looks too difficult
I'm already butchering butchering easier
last names than that Oh get out the way
we're not friendly this is what we get
for using cockpit view Miguel's become a
rayji driver someone lap I gotta stop
watching shaking me sick
that's the lap that's it show the crash
oh we're still spinning out show the
crash how do you say that's a third at
the end there just by accelerating past
everyone
that's hilarious we can fast-forward the
replay okay let's let's check this out
let's check this out
that's the boring bits yeah I guess you
can fast-forward every 30 seconds oh
yeah okay no changing camera find that
we're gonna find that hot crash here in
a second
I'm just not gonna try Chris it's too
much Nordschleife almost like Norrish
life like not there I tried it all right
Steve cat 46 enjoy playing four to seven
he said thank you for the stream he's
gonna go play some four to seven now
all right get all the way we can
accelerate past you see ya I think that
was a GTR I'm pretty sure we're all over
the place
now we're gonna accelerate where's the
home stretch where we we somehow get
third while crashing into everyone else
there's WRX or what appeared to be one
my favorite I like this though my
favorite replay camera was from some of
the Namco publish okay what it cuts off
at the crash that was the best part I'm
gonna save this oh come on man that was
the best part and now you're not gonna
see it it clearly replayed the thing
right when you hit the car now we can
pause it pause it impact wait I ready
yeah whatever it's fine
go show me some is there anything else
you want to show off before we kind of
wrap this up just make sure I didn't
miss anything in the menus okay
well go through the menus real quick
but yeah that was sports a motorsport
seven if you have Ultimate Edition
obviously you've already played or are
gonna be playing if not it comes out
today
I would imagine 12:00 a.m. Eastern which
would be 9 p.m. here not positive
someone can confirm or deny that in chat
what should be out this morning like not
this actual morning what the Tuesday
morning so yeah we cool we're gonna go
through some of the the menus here see
if there's anything else to show off you
guys want to see anything else just tell
us someone says show the gt40 those
Jonas GS I will also add another
component of this game is this thing
called milestone so as you keep
accumulating XP sorry our mouth oh yeah
as you can get XP and level up you have
the choice of getting credits a discount
on a particular car or a another outfit
Oh someone wants to see that any menus -
sure that seems a pretty good one yeah I
don't forget guys as anvil one gaming in
YouTube chat mentioned if you haven't
already subscribed or hit that like
button and twitch you guys should do
that so that you guys get informed on
when we do do our live streams they are
at 11 a.m. every day but also we have a
bunch of different features going up
gameplay so if you're interested in that
you know hit that sub button here we go
to the tune up tune set up alright so
you can change the tire pressure
and this is currently just for the
Sylvia right yes four years and just
your gears alignment line okay Tyrol
Springs damping yeah dick Savini I could
have used I could have been more destiny
jokes but I'll save them for a while
we're gonna be streaming tomorrow
destiny to weekly reset I think last
week gives me and Rob so it might be me
and John Luke this week or it could be
Rob John let's see but if you're into
that destiny to tomorrow and there's a
lot of stuff you can do here so it looks
like you could do quite a bit in terms
of the tuning yeah 20 20 horsepower
upgrade sounds significant doesn't do
that do they tell you if the stickers
gives you horsepower because that's what
does a terrible job cause we used to
take in high school once racing stripes
and just any stickers where you said
joke that's like oh that's two that's
two horsepower I just gave because we
couldn't afford to really upgrade or
mater cars back then
whoo that's a nice wing mushi's Belon
will be playing destiny too tomorrow
Wednesday will be an interesting one
because we have the lobby at 11:00 but I
also want to say that Wednesday is when
the start Star Wars Battlefront 2 beta
lux
I think it's Wednesday so it might end
up streaming that day for a second time
during the day or we might just hold off
until Thursday the stream Battlefront to
maybe get like deeper into the beta than
just like opening part of it let's have
the spoilers were somewhat adjustable
right from that last room that you're in
well you could change I will go ahead
and oh you got a crate you can open was
there driver gear now we don't want to
transfer a car yeah yeah through has
300,000 credits for the stream let's do
this we're doing it for you guys alright
I believe that your legendary car its
chance I know but it's gonna be
legendary I smell it oh you know what
that could have been cooler no like I
know I would love to see a picture on my
best Hey s2000 it's a nice car I would
like to see it I'd like to see us to
write a feature on like best animated
car stack openings car stone is it I
think so I think plants versus zombies
is pretty good car stones is pretty good
because there's always like relative to
the piece the expansion you're open wow
you got wrecked yeah for $300 ex this is
terrible oh man what a bad box opening
jeez alright anyways guys any last
thoughts Miguel as the reviewer for
forcible of our crate my ass they're not
that lucky any last thoughts here before
we send off before you actually finish
finish up for your review you know
thanks for joining us this was a lot of
fun and I also like
I took this opportunity to makes more
progress in the career so kill two birds
that's awesome
sorry I tried to go to full camera but
someone broke my setup I'm gonna blame
it on Mary and Michael Hardy because
that's usually who does it but I really
appreciate you guys tuning in remember
if you haven't subbed and you haven't
liked to do that tune in tomorrow I'll
purge some destiny to stuff and also
tune in tomorrow for the full review of
Motorsports for some water sports 7
coming from Miguel for the meantime go
check out the review progress and again
thank you guys for tuning in and see you
guys tomorrow hopefully later later